hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
the impact of mbt septa typer the leahy
experience
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by brooker
daltonics to learn more visit
brooker.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker felicia
meda
mt senior technologist microbiology
laboratory
leahy hospital and medical center for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen felicia you
may now begin your presentation
thank you for having me so again my name
is felicia maida and i am a senior tech
2
at leahy hospital and medical center in
burlington mass
i have been working in the microbiology
department for about 30 years
and after this past year actually seems
like more of a lifetime so
can't wait for this cover to go away um
okay
a little bit about our hospital
so as i said um we are out of burlington
massachusetts
massachusetts sorry we are located
about 20 minutes northwest of boston
so leahy serves about 3 000 outpatients
a year and has 335
in-patient beds we also have an acute
ambulatory care center our
emergency department is a level two
trauma center
that operates 24 hours a day seven days
a week and we have a
the staff that we have on hand
teach at tufts university school of
medicine
we are teaching hospital at tufts
university school of medicine excuse me
and our physicians actually hold
teaching assignments at harvard medical
school
and boston university school of medicine
so that's a little background about our
hospital and now i will move on to
life before welding
so life before maldi we did use
biochemicals some of them here
bioesculin salt
tubecoin to name a few we also use
instrumentation as well
i'd like to now review the workflow
in our department for when a positive
blood
flags excuse me
so the positive blood will alert on our
instrument
we would pull the positive blood
we will make our gram stain
we aliquot three ml of blood into
a sterile plastic tube and then we would
wait for our gram stain to dry read the
gram stain
and depending on what the organism is
we would well no matter what the
organism is we would phone it to the
appropriate floor provider
depending on what the organism organism
is that we see
in the gram stain we would then set up
the biochemicals and sub it to
the appropriate media as needed
so to give you some examples on how we
would work this out
if we had gram-positive coccine clusters
we would sub this plate this to
a sheep blood auger and we would add a
furozone disc
which is also known as fx disk
and we use the fx disk to rule out
micrococcus at 24 hours
we also would place three drops of the
blood into
a tube co egg and we would then wait
examine that at two hours four hours and
24 hours to see if there is any
coagulation to rule out staph aureus
if we had gram-positive cocci in pairs
and chains
we would plate it to a sheet blood we
would add an option disc which is the p
disc so at 24 hours we can look and that
will help us rule out
strep numeral we would also add a
chocolate auger
and we then would also take three drops
of blood and put it into the bioelectric
tube and the salt tube
which i showed you on the previous slide
those tubes we use
to rule out enterococcus at 24 hours so
you can see
we're plating it we're using
biochemicals and it's taking us about 24
hours to get any type of identification
for gram-negative rods excuse me
we would plate this to a sheep a
chocolate
i'm a conchi and a cna now the reason
behind the cna
is we use this just to make sure we
do not miss any gram-positive bacteria
that could have been growing in the
blood that we did not see on the gram
stain
for gram-positive rods we would plate
this to a sheep
and a bioesco and tube and again the
bioescond tube is to help us rule out
listeria at 24 hours again
so as i was saying at 24 hours we can
determine
a lot of what's happening with the
organism that we saw in the gram stain
we absorb observe the growth on the
plates
we will then identify the organism if
possible
with the biochemicals that were set up
we would look at the morphology
on the plates and hopefully between the
biochemicals and the morphology we are
able to
have some type of an identification of
the organism
if there is no identification at this
point
then we would move on to other
biochemicals if we needed to
or use our instrumentation
at that point
so if we didn't have that id at 24 hours
and we needed to put it on
instrumentation or we set up other
biochemicals
now we're talking another 24 hours
before we get that identification
so here we are 48 hours later and we
finally hopefully will have an
identification
so just to kind of review start to
finish
using biochemicals before maldi was
implemented
it's going to take us 24 to 48 hours
before we're able to
identify that organism so in june
of 2015 we implemented
our maldi biotyper
we performed a validation on
approximately a hundred different
isolates
over a period of a few months and
multiple technologists were involved
when we did this we did have 100
accuracy from this validation
i'm just going to talk about the sepsi
typo and the rapid type c type of
validation since we're on the slide
for the sepsi type of validation we used
around worried
or excuse me 80 organisms
mix of gram negatives and gram positives
and we had about 91 percent
identify using the sepsi typer
and when the rapidsepsi typer was
implemented we just did a very
limited validation and that identified
about 90 percent
of our positive blood cultures during
that validation
so just to give you an idea of what
happens in
our microbiology department
we have multiple technologists that run
targets daily
and we use that to identify our
organisms
so it's great because instead of waiting
24 hours for identification
using the multibiotyper we're now
getting identification out the same
day each bench
is responsible for their own target so
our setup is we have four different
benches everybody has their own target
so everybody can work at their own pace
and do their own work
we do give priority to the blood bench
uh
so if people have to run targets you
know people are very good about
giving each other the time to get on and
especially like i said if the
blood bench needs to get on there they
are the first to get on there
so implementation of
our sepsi typer came in october
of 2017
so i will review the workflow that we
use
for the sepsi typer as to when
this was introduced
the positive blood alerts we pull the
positive blood
we make our gram stain we aliquot the
three mls of blood
into the sterile plastic tube
we then read our gram stain again
we will report it and we will put it to
the
appropriate plates
from here we save those
aliquots of any other positive bloods
that have gone positive
up until 10 30. at 10 30 we then take
any aliquots that we have that need
an identification and
we will then put that on the sepsi typer
and have identifications hopefully on
those different patients for
our rounds at 11 30. we do infectious
disease rounds daily
at our hospital and we like to give as
much
information on patients that we can at
that time
once id rounds are over any other
positive bloods
that flag we then again batch
and we'll leave our tubes under the hood
and we'll do another run
at 2 pm in the afternoon so this is
this workflow we were batching the
bloods would come off we would batch
so twice a day we were getting out
identification for positive bloods
so how is the sepsi typer for performed
the way that we have our this is just a
way that we set up our algorithm and
i'm sure facility facility is different
so for us so you would set up sepsi
typer if the first bottle
or set is positive with gram-negative
rods
gram-positive cocci or large gram
positive rights
if your second set turns positive from
the same day
we don't have the technologists set up
the sepsi typer again we are assuming
that if it's grim negative rods and
we get an e coli and the first set that
the gram negative rods in the second
step from the same day is also going to
be the e coli
in our laboratory we do it a little
differently for coed negative staff so
if you do have a collect negative staff
of gram-positive cocci
on the second set from the first day the
same day
we would also run the sepsi typer
if we have a new bottle from a different
day
and it had gram-negative rods we would
set it up we want to make sure that the
second
day or a different day is the same as
what was previous if it was grim
positive rods we don't set it up
we see a lot of contamination so we
don't take the time we just wait
for that to grow and if it was
gram-positive cocci
again we're not going to set it up but
if it is greater than three days or
it's collect negative staff we would set
it up and again just the algorithm
that we use here at leahey hospital
medical center
so what is the procedure for sepsi typer
i'm going to just talk you through this
you take one ml of blood
you place that in a sterile tube you're
going to add
200 microliters of the lysis reagent
you're going to vortex that and then
spin it
you're then going to discard the
supernatant
and you should have a pellet that's
visible
if you don't have a pellet that's
visible at this point that's okay
but we like to see a palette knowing
that we do have some kind of organism in
there but we still will
continue with it even if we don't have a
pellet
we then add one ml of wash and we spin
that for one minute and then we discard
the supernatant
you have to be very careful when you're
discarding the supernatant though
because that pellet as you're discarding
the blood and the supernatant that's in
there
sometimes the pellet can be sticky and
it can come up and if it
if you if that pellet gets moved at all
then you really want to go back
and re-spin it because you don't want to
lose any of that pellet
because that has the organism in it so
the next part is the extraction
so the extraction on top of what we just
did
we're then going to add 300 microliters
of the hplc
water we resuspend that and then we add
900 microliters of ethanol
we'll mix that suspension and then we
spin that for two minutes
again we're going to discard the
supernatant careful not to touch
the pellet we do use these very fine tip
pipettes that work great for this
we are going to then air dry that pellet
for five minutes
we want to try to get off as much of
that ethanol residue as we
possibly can then we need to make a one
to one with the formic acid and the
acetal nitrile
and resuspend so depending on the size
of the pellet
you can kind of play with the amount of
formic acid and acetonitrile that you
need
we average about 25 microliters
depending on the size
of size of the pellet so it could be 25
microliters of formic acid along with
the 25 microliters of the seed and
nitrile
and then we resuspend that we spin that
for two minutes
again discard the supernatant um oh
excuse me we don't discard supernatant
at this point the supernatant is what we
use
on the target and then that gets read by
the maldi
um at that point so
all in all total turnaround time
you know approximately 25 to 30 minutes
with the hands-on time maybe 15 minutes
it's it's tedious because there's a lot
of
spinning and discarding and spinning
um but idea identification
like i said in about 25 to 30 minutes
so how does this affect
patient antibiotic therapy i have a few
cases
that i'm going to go over
that we had here in our hospital
so the first case study we had
a positive blood flag we did a gram
stain on it and as you can see here we
had
small gram negative rods
we plated it to our plates that we would
our blood our chocolate our
cna and our mcconkey
we phoned it to the floor to let them
know
that the patient had gram-negative roots
we then performed our sepsi taper
and the result was a bacteroides
fragilist
needless to say we were a little
surprised to see this
we had already alerted the care team
that they had a grim negative rod
earlier
after reading the gram stain and now
this
changes the whole aspect of patient
therapy
because we're dealing with an anaerobe
versus some type of gram-negative rod
so this was a great situation for us
where we called the care team we let
them know there was a gram-negative rod
and then half an hour
or however long later i don't know what
time this was called
all of a sudden we have an
identification of b frag
which is an anaerobe which requires
different
antibiotic therapy so this was great for
us
it's a great feeling to know that you
can change the patient
care within 24 hours i mean this is
being done
so fast and we can let the care team
know so they can treat appropriately
so our next case study um same thing
the blood culture flag positive
we did a gram stain this one
came up as gram positive cocci in
clusters
so again we plated this to our
blood plate we added the fx disc
and we called it to the care team
letting them know that
it was grim positive cocci and clusters
suggesting staph species
we were in our sepsis hyper and
voila aerococcus urane which is not a
staphylococcus species
so again you can see the impact of
patient
care and therapy due to the maldi
and the sepsi typer and what it's
what it just does to the laboratory for
us so
aerocarcus urinate as we know is part of
the streptococcus
family so it was great again for us to
call and let the care team know that
it was a streptococcus aerocarcus
urinary and they were then able to
change the patient therapy and treat
appropriately
so again just it's for us it's just it's
amazing because you're going from 24
hours to 48 hours for an identification
and especially something like aerocarcus
which would take
20 48 to 72 hours it's just such a great
instrument
so our implementation of the rapid sepsi
typer
came in 2000
april of 2019 sorry
so the workflow for the rapid subsidy
typer
is very similar to what it was for the
sepsi typer
um just a few differences on this
so the positive blood will alert we pull
the
pull the blood we make our gram stain
put it to our plates
we alight our three mls
we read our gram stain we phone it
to the floor the physician the care team
and then instead of waiting
and leaving our tube for other positives
to that 10 30 am mark
we now will perform our rapid sepsis
diapers
as we go so with the rapid sepsi typer
there is no batching
as we batched prior to this for just
sepsis hyper
and due to that we're able to again
get the results out to our infectious
disease department
for that 11 30 a.m rounding
so the workflow for the rapid sepsi
typer
is pretty much the same as the sepsi
typer it's just we don't have that
extraction process
so i'll go through the rapid subsidy
type of workflow with you
so again you would take your one amount
of blood
you put in your microcentrifuge you add
your 200 microliters of lysis
you're going to vortex that for 10
seconds you're going to spin it for 2
minutes
you're going to decant your supernatant
again
carefully avoiding that pellet
we're going to then add one ml of the
wash
we'll resuspend by
pipetting up and down we will spin that
for one minute
we will then remove the supernatant
again using that fine tip
pipet and this time
the supernatant is discarded because for
the rapid pepsi typer we're actually
using
the pellet so this is one of the main
differences
between the sepsi type and the rapid
pepsi type the rapid pepsi typer we stop
at this point
where we have the pellet and we're going
to use that pellet on our target
for the identification versus the sepsi
typer
at this point we would continue with the
extraction process and then we would be
using
the supernatant to put on our target for
identification
so for my third case study
this was using the rapid pepsi typer
we had a blood flag positive
the gram stain was performed
and it showed gram-positive rods
so this we would plate to
our blood plate and
wear it with small grain positive rise
we probably would
set up a bioelectron with this
when we performed the sepsi typer the
result for this one was an actinotignum
shalei
which is formerly known as actinobaculum
shalei
so due to this being an unorgan unusual
organism in the bloodstream this is not
something that we tend to see
very much of we did a little bit more of
an investigation to see if we could
figure out
where this may have come from so when we
looked at the patient's
chart we did see that the patient also
had
a urine culture that was positive for
greater than 100 000 colony-forming
units per ml
of these pinpoint colonies due to that
like growth of the organism
the technologist was not able to
identify the organism using the maldi
when we let them know what was growing
in the blood culture
we were able to pull the plates out and
look at the colony morphology
do a gram stain on it and we also
performed a pyr
which was positive and for our
actinobaculum
we should have a positive pyr this
enabled us to sign the urine culture out
as
presumptive actinotignum at this point
and then on day two so at
48 hours the colonies were bigger and
they were
able to run the multita malditos
and confirm this identification so this
another
great situation where we were able to
help the urine bench identify the
organism there because it was in the
blood culture
and if it wasn't for the rapid sepsi
type or identifying it
the urine culture would have waited
another 24 hours for that identification
to go out
so just to review the timeline
comparisons for all three methods
the first one is obviously biochemicals
and instrumentation
so hands-on is quicker it's about 10
minutes
you're making your gram stain you're
plating it but you're waiting 24 to 48
hours
to get that id
that you can report out for the
maldi sepsi typer it's about 15 minutes
hands on
and we're looking at about 25 to 30
minutes
to get the identification after it runs
on the maldi
and then for the rapid sepsi typer it's
quick it's about five minutes hands on
tech time and you know 15 to 20 minutes
total turnaround time for the
identification
as well
so i did ask one of our infectious
disease
doctors as i have him here is dr m
if he would just give me a comment or
thoughts on
our new system when we brought up the
rapid
sepsi typer into play and
dr m's comment to me was patients are
put
on therapy a day earlier due to the
rapid mbt
sepsi typer um
so doc dr m also had a shazam moment as
i would call it and i'll explain his
shazam moment in the next slide
so we had a positive blood culture that
flagged
it had gram positive cocci and pairs and
chains so we did
phone this to the floor or the care team
to let them know
that it was grim positive cocci and
pairs and chains
and we probably suggested streptococcus
or enterococcus at this point
we performed our rapid pepsi typer
and we ended up identifying this
organism as a beta-hemolytic strap group
a
so as you know this is a very serious
organism in the bloodstream and we did
look into the patient's chart
to see what else was going on with this
patient
while investigating we found the patient
had
two wound cultures and when the
technologists read them at 24 hours they
were
super pinpoint and they just not didn't
feel they were going to be able to get
any type of an identification from them
so they re-incubated the plates well due
to the identification in the blood
culture
we did perform a latex
on these tiny colonies
and we were able to see agglutination
in group a and we were able to sign both
of these wound cultures out as
group a strep so it was nice to be able
to put
everything together to let dr m know
that it was in the blood culture it was
in the wound culture
and it was again great antibiotic
therapy
for him and he knew
exactly what was going on with the
patient
um i have a little bit of data
here that i was just going to review
with you that we took from
october 2018 from to september of 2019
and it was the total sepsi typers tested
so we did about 708
the total identified were about 73
oh sorry so here's the chat i know it's
very hard
to see um
so i'm just gonna go over a couple
of the numbers in
february of 2019
we only had 48 identified that was the
least
identified over the whole year of
looking at this data and the highest
number
that we had was in
december of 2018
with 95 identification
and throughout the chart um again i
apologize for how small it is but
you can see the numbers vary so again 48
was the lowest 95 was the highest
but we had a lot of 70s in there there
were some 80s some in the 60s
and so this could just
be due to
um organism if we didn't have a pellet i
did talk about we would still continue
to use it if we had a palette
and this is what sepsi type or an wraps
rapid sepsi typer
so just a little bit of data to show you
and i believe sepsi typer does state
that it will
identify organisms 70 of the
time which like i said if i go back here
you can see of the 708 that we tested we
did have a total identification
of 73 percent so we are falling
within those limits so in conclusion
i would like to just say that
the rapid sepsi type or workflow is an
extreme
asset in our laboratory
the result as i've demonstrated are
determined within minutes
of the blood culture flagging positive
there's no more waiting 24 to 48 hours
it provides accurate identification as i
went over when
we have never had a miss we have never
had anything misidentified
it provides results to our clinicians in
a more timely manner
like i said they're getting these
results by 11 30 and then any time it
comes off we're just running it as we go
and the results are going in
so you know they're getting results the
same day
and the rapid detection is also
decreasing
the hospital length of stay by about two
and a half days in our hospital
this also gives us the ability to
decrease the amount of biochemicals that
we order
and that we use in the laboratory and it
is a useful tool for our antimicrobial
stewardship
i'd also like to say that our
technologists love this instrument
it's very easy to run it's very
user-friendly
again it's just a great asset to
our laboratory and
with that i would like to say thank you
and i will open it up to questions thank
you felicia for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
how long did it take you to validate the
rapid sepsi typer
hi so as far as the validation for the
rapid sepsi typer
um like i said in the presentation we
did do
a limited validation due to
we had such a larger validation when we
did the actual sepsi typer so this was
just very quick
we knew that the sepsi typo worked this
was just a matter of instead of doing
the extraction process
you stopped before then so we had
already gone through
all of that with the regular sepsi type
so
this was very quick and easy to do
thank you felicia we have another
question here have you ever reported an
organism from the rapid sepsi typer that
did not grow on the plates
the next day or was a different organism
i can honestly say that we have not
what we have found is organisms
sometimes that we
weren't sure even existed where we are
finding more organisms
we're identifying i should say more
organisms using
the rapid separate sepsi typer than if
we were using typical
uh biochemicals so i can honestly say
that
everything that we have run on the sepsi
type or we have had match on the plates
the next day and confirmation due to
morphology
thank you felicia our next question is
what were the reasons that your lab was
able to move from batched sexy type
or prep to on-demand prep with the rapid
sexy type of protocol
so what happened is the regular sepsi
type or like i stated
because it had that extraction process
we just felt that
because it took a little longer we would
batch them
and then we would go into that
extraction process and work
with as many positive blood cultures
that we had
due to the rapid sepsi typer and not
using that extraction
process that enabled us to be able to
work
as each blood culture flagged positive
so we could just run it
as we go instead of waiting until that
10 30 mark
great thank you we have another question
how could this be used with the micro
scan
that is actually the instrumentation
that we have at leahey hospital medical
center
and it works great um they we
it's lab pro so it's a great system
we have everything hooked up as far as
maldi goes
rapid sepsi type is a little different
because it is the research
side so the research site is done
you are actually manually entering
versus when you're using the maldi with
the micro scan
that's an all automated system through
lab pro
so the rapid sepsi type again is used on
the research side so that's manual so
everything is entered manually
into the multi-typer and then we enter
it manually
into our system for the maldi in the
micro scan that is all automated so all
of that information from
our benches go into the maldi goes into
the micro scan and the micro scan then
is putting that information into our
system
thank you felicia our next question from
the audience is
do you proceed to full extraction if no
identification
we have done that in the past so yes
depending
on what we see if we're unsure
of what it is and we really want to get
the identification out we will continue
with the extraction process
and we have done that and what is the
acceptable score to call it a good
identification
so for a sepsi typer because you're
working on the research side they do
lower the score a little bit
so as long as you receive a 1.8 or
higher
then you are able to use that as a
preliminary id
into our system
great thank you and our next question
here is how do you report out your
identification
seeing that it is identified from
research use only
so we have come up with a comment
that states the identification it's a
preliminary
identification from a liquid culture
and we would have confirmation the next
day
so let's just say for instance we had an
identification of an e coli
then the next day we would look at the
plates look at the morphology
and then we would run the actual
organism on the maldi typer on the
clinical side for
confirmation of that e coli we would
then take out
our preliminary results and leave that
as an e coli
thank you felicia and our next question
is
how many samples can you treat at the
same time with the rapid sepsi typer
so as far as as many samples um
we because we do it as we go or
sometimes we will have multiple blood
cultures that flag
we come in at 7am so if we have four or
five blood cultures that go positive
right at seven a.m between seven and
seven
thirty we will so to speak back to our
rapid sepsi type
at that point so we could potentially be
doing
five at a time but we wouldn't wait till
that 10 30 mark
and because the target has 48 spots on
it
we can run we usually run them in
multiples just to make sure because
we've done
the proc that extraction well not an
extraction but we've done the lysis
process
so we will run spot it twice because if
the first one doesn't work we want to
hopefully get it to work on that second
spot so
we have like i said 48 slots so
depending we can run you know if we have
five
positive blood cultures that only takes
up 10 spots on the target and we can run
those
10 spots you know at the same time and
within 10 minutes we'll have an
identification for
five different samples
how do you identify the 27 excuse me the
27 percent of organisms that the rapid
sepsi type or cannot id
um we depending we do have other
instrumentation
in the laboratory or we will wait um set
up biochemicals if need be
or we'll just wait until the next day
for the organism to grow and then we
would just run it on the maldives hyper
and in your study what is the percentage
of agreement
in comparison to reference technique
culture
any numbers about discrepancies errors
etc
i don't have that information
with me right now um i could look into
that and get back to you
perfect thank you felicia our next
question here is
did rapid sexy typer allow you to move
away from expensive
pcr testing if so how was the process
of changing
uh we did not have pcr testing
when rapid when the maldi was introduced
so
that was really never uh that didn't
really affect us
okay great and are you able to make
identifications when a blood culture
contains multiple organisms
if the blood culture does have multiple
organisms we would not put it on the
sepsi typer
we would just wait and for that 24 hours
to see what's growing on the plates
and therefore if it is polymicrobic we
would just put on the maldi
um to get both identifications
okay thank you felicia our next question
with lower score less than 1.8
do you report to genus level only
we do not um if it does go below 1.8
if we were to call it for example um
gram-positive cocci and clusters
suggesting staff let's say we had an
identification
of a staff epiderm epidermidis
at 1.79 which is below that 1.8
we still would not report that as a
co-negative staff we would just leave
the gram stain in
stating its gram-positive cocci impairs
and clusters suggesting stuff
what we would do is as i stated we do
have
infectious disease rounds at 11 30.
we would let the id physician know
it looks like it's going to be a quiet
negative staff we didn't get it high
enough on the sepsi typer
and you know we'll let you know more
tomorrow so we do give
the id staff information but it's not
anything that we put into the patient's
chart or into the system
or that we would call thank you felicia
our next question here is
will it id mycobacteria species 2 like
mac or mac we do use the maldi typer for
our microbacteriology lab yes okay
great and uh what do you do if there's
more than one organism
seen in the original blood gram stain
so this we again um if we saw
gram-negative rods and gram-positive
cocci in pairs and clusters we would
just report both of those
to the floor we would put that in the
patient's chart
and again we wouldn't go any further
due to it being multiple organisms we
would just wait for the 24 hours for
them to grow
and then perform identification on maldi
the next day
and can you use rapid protocol pellet
for ast
we do not we actually have to use an
organism in our laboratory
okay thank you honey sorry the colony
okay thank you and our next question is
how about the cost of identification
using
rapid scentsy type
i don't have that information in front
of me
so that's something that i could get
back to you with
okay perfect and our next question here
is were you able to identify
any fungi
we are in the process
of getting ready to do a validation for
our mycology laboratory
great thank you so much felicia and this
question
may have been answered already but i'm
going to ask it anyway how about
multiple organisms in the blood so yes
that was question i have answered and
again
depending on what is in there we would
report it
put it in the patient's chat but we
would not perform a sepsi type
okay thank you and for other benches do
you use a suspension of an isolate grown
from
a colony no suspension is necessarily
necessary so if the organism is growing
and we have a colony we just use that
colony put it right on the target and
let's run on the maldi
and is the rapid scentsy type of run on
all shifts
it is run on first and second shift our
third shift
we have a
we only have one person that comes down
to the microbiology laboratory on our
third shift
and they just pull the bloods and they
call them
and the rest is left for our first shift
okay let's see we've got some more
questions
um what percentage of the questionable
id
agreed with a final id
um again if we
had anything
that was below 1.8
we don't use that for identification so
we would just wait for the organism to
grow the next day
okay thank you felicia our next question
is
um let's see what was the percentage of
identification for the sexy typer method
the longer method as you said your rapid
scentsy type of identification is 70
70 so as far as the sepsi
typer method i don't have the exact
numbers
um but i believe it is
higher just due to that extraction
process because once
you use that extraction and you're
adding
your ethanol and you're really
pulling out those proteins you do get a
higher number
so like i had said previously if we do a
rapid sepsi type and we don't
get an identification we could move on
to the extraction process
and we usually would get it i don't have
the exact percentages
in front of me but it's definitely a
higher percentage using the extraction
versus not
okay thank you felicia we have a few
more questions
what are the sexy type of results in
cases where you have mixed infections or
polymicrobial samples
does the sepsi type are pick up both if
you do
more than one spot how many spots do you
spot when you perform
rapid scentsy type or sepsi typer
okay so um we actually have
had in cis situations where we did
see um gram-positive cocci
say in a gram stain and when we did the
rapid subsea type or all of a sudden we
did
have a gram-negative identification now
my understanding of the
sepsi typer is even if it is poly
microbic it will it will identify the
higher
weight of the organism's protein that's
in there so even if you do
have multiple organisms that you don't
realize you have multiple organisms
if you run that you would still get
an identification um we're hesitant to
report that or we will go back and we
will
resub the bottle we will look so example
if we had gram positive cocci and then
we had
an e coli that identified on the sepsi
typer
we would go back we would look at the
gram stain we would see if there were
any gram negative rods in there
if there weren't then we would wait till
the next day
we haven't had any situations where that
has happened that it's been due to
cross-contamination or anything it
actually has grown out the next
day but we will wait that 24 hours
um just to make sure we don't
obviously want to report an incorrect
result on a blood culture
um as far as
how many spots again like i said we
usually
will run two spots so we use the
pellet that we have and we will take
that it can sometimes it can be sticky
and again with them all the heavier you
know lighter is better it's micro
organisms that they're looking for so
it's the more protein you have in there
it doesn't always read it
properly so um just two spots is what we
use we overlay that with formic acid we
put our matrix on we put it on the
instrument
and hopefully get an identification
great thank you felicia we have time for
just a few more questions and i want to
remind the audience that any questions
we don't have time for today will be
answered by the speaker via the contact
information
that you use to register for this
webinar so we have here's our next
question
do you use rapid protocol for
mycobacteria blood culture
that is done in our myco
bacteriology laboratory i do not work
back
there so i could find out that
information for you
and get you that answer
okay perfect and our next question is if
the id is e coli
how will you report this knowing there's
there's a possibility that this is um
could be a shigella species
for us um we have never
identified an e coli from the maldi tof
that the next day has been
a shigella so shigella is really not
something that we worry about
at our facility um if it comes out
e coli we report it as an e coli and
like i said
um we've been doing this since 2015 so
over the past five years we have never
had an e coli that actually grew out as
a shigella the next day we've never had
any discrepancies at all with our e coli
okay thank you felicia our next question
here is
does the stewardship team change therapy
based on
id along from sepsi typer versus having
an ast result or a result from a
resistance
gene especially in the case of
gram-negative rods
so for our stewardship team like i said
this is
a great tool for them and they will
change their therapy based on that
identification from sepsi typer
as far as resistance genes you know
sepsi type or multi-type doesn't do ast
results so therefore we can only give
them
identification and again they will
change therapy as needed
great thank you so much felicia we have
one last question here
sometimes you cannot see a polymicrobial
on the gram stain
have you had discrepant results in the
case where one of these samples got put
on the maldi
and there were two organisms present in
the pvc
again we really have not had any
discrepancies
at all using our maldi
our sepsi type or our rapid sepsi typer
um
like i said it's a great instrument for
us it
again it's we love it we just absolutely
love it and we really have not seen any
discrepancies
everything that we've reported has
confirmed the next day by culture
thank you felicia do you have any final
comments for our audience before we go
just that like i said it's a great asset
for our laboratory
again our technologists you know love
this instrument
it makes life easier for
us it's great for patient care our id
doctors love it um we are
very thankful that it was made i guess
well we want to thank you again felicia
for your time today and for your
important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor brooker
daltonix for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye